(craquement de branche)
- Le son des branches
qui craquent n'annonçait rien
de bon.
- Quand je suis revenue, c'était
cassé ici. Là, c'est sûr
les fils électriques, donc,
il n'y a pas d'électricité.
(explosion)
- Une nuit d'horreur. Il y avait
le bruit de fracas de la glace
et vous aviez les
transformateurs qui explosaient.
Et il y t t t des éclairs.
- Du 5 au 10 janvier 1998,
100 millimètre e e pluie
verglaçante s'abattent
sur le sud du Québec.
Près d'un million et demi
de foyers sont plongés dans
le noir.
000000 kilomètres de lignes
électriques sont tombés.
ANDRÉ CAILLÉ, ancien président-
directeur général d'Hydro-Québec
- Ça fait 25 ans.
- Après toutes ces années,
DGDGDGDG d'Hydro-Québec à l'époe
n'a rien oublié. Ses pylônes
lui semblaient quasi
indestructibles.
- J'ai entendu le son lugubre,
lugubre, le son, quand ça frappe
le sol. On n'avait jamais parlé
que ça, ça pouvait s'effondrer,
c'était pas dans l'esprit de
personne. C'est une affaire
qui était impossible.
- Autour de Lucien Bouchard,
la cellule de crise s'active.
Nous avons invité le docteur
Luc Boileau.
- À ce moment directeur de santé
publique de la Montérégie,
il est aussi en première ligne.
Au moins 28 vies ont été
fauchées par le froid,
les incendies et les chutes
de glace.
Dr LUC BOILEAU, directeur
régional de santé publique
- Beaucoup de traumatismes.
Les gens gt,t,t,t,t, tombaient,
se fracturaient partout...
tombaient du toit en essayant
d'enlever la glace sur le toit.
- Cette crise, dit-il,
l'a préparé à en vivre
e,e,e,e,e, quoiqu'un peu
différente.
- Pendant la crise du verglas,
on cherchait à regrouper
les gens ensemble. Pendant
la crise pandémique,
on cherchait à les isoler.
Aujourd'hui, je pense qu'on a
pris beaucoup d'expérience
au Québec sur la gestion
deenenenenents comme ça
qui nous surprennent.
ANDRÉ CAILLÉ, président-
r r r r r r général d'Hydro-Quéc
- Au lieu de durer six semaines,
ça durait une semaine.
MARC MORISSETTE, ingénieur
en planification du réseauprincc
- Bien, c'est sûr qu'il y a eu
un éveil.
- Hydro-Québec a depuis renforcé
son réseau...
... noecececececec des pylônes
antichute en cascade...
le verglas demeure tout de même
la menace numéro un.
MARC MORISSETTE, ingénieur
en planification du réseau
principal, Hydro-Québec
- Depuis 98, je dirais,
on n'a jamais arrêté
de réfléchir là-dessus. Donc,
la stratégie verglas, elle est
là depuis le lendemain
du verglas de 98.UnUnUnUnUnUne é
près de six milliards
de dollars.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers
Radio-Canada, Montréa